-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Guys, I'm so excited
about this --
Shawn Mendes is here
and he is my --
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
He is my cohost tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right,
Shawn Mendes is here
and like you've never
seen him before --
with sleeves.
-Oh.
-Yes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Do you guys know
that Shawn was born in Canada?
-Yes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Now I'm trying to figure out,
did he really want to be here
or was he just too polite
to say no?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Let's get to some news.
I read that Amazon stock
just crashed
after the company reported
a loss of nearly $4 billion.
-Wow.
-Yeah, Amazon stock is crashing.
Netflix stock is crashing.
Right now, everyone
who invested in Beanie Babies
is like, "Well, well, well,
who's the financial
[ Laughter and applause ]
genius now?"
But this should help business --
once the bad news broke,
Amazon executives spent
the night getting drunk
and ordering stuff
off of Amazon, so there you go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Go right back up.
Right now,
Jeff Bezos is so stressed,
his hair grew in
and then fell out again.
It's just unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a tough day for Bezos
because his net worth shrunk
by $13 billion.
[ Awws ]
[ Laughter ]
We'll be sending around
a basket for collections.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, his network shrunk
by $13 billion
and, due to cold weather,
his rocket shrunk three inches.
It's terrible.
-Whoa!
[ Laughter and oohs ]
-Worse.
-Whoa!
Oh! Oh!
Some more business news --
I saw that, last year,
Subway closed more
than 1,000 locations in the U.S.
[ Awws ]
One thousand stores is a lot.
That's over 50,000 footlongs
of retail space.
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of annoying
because the stores are gone,
but the smell of nine-grain
honey oat bread still remains.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
Snapple announced
that it's going to rebrand
its diet Snapple drinks
as Snapple Zero Sugar.
But don't worry.
It'll still taste like
the drink you've never tried.
[ Laughter ]
Diet -- No, I'm going to get
the Peach.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
Tom Cruise has revealed
that the title
of "Mission: Impossible 7"
will be
"Mission: Impossible --
Dead Reckoning Part One."
[ Oohs ]
So far,
the impossible mission is
fitting that entire title
on a marquee.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's a long title.
Right now, our movie titles
are starting to look like
the poster for Coachella.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Oh, my --
[ Cacophony of cheering
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
This is --
[ Laughs ]
Wow!
Shawn Mendes, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
Wow! Wow!
Shawn Mendes,
you're young, you're talented,
you're good-looking.
It is like --
It's like looking into a mirror.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel differently.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you want to try
some monologue jokes?
-Yeah, sure.
Let's do it, guys.
Well, I heard that, this year,
New York City is getting
60 new electric buses.
-Yeah, electric buses.
Or, as they're also known,
subways.
[ Laughter ]
How about this one?
Try this one.
-Yeah, hey, I saw
that a new poll said
that every average American
sets four different alarms
to wake up in the morning.
Did you know that?
-Yeah. No, I didn't know.
The poll also found that the
average person's spouse says,
"If that goes off a fifth time,
we're getting a divorce."
[ Laughter ]
-Yep. Four alarms.
Everyone's like,
"We don't know why
we're so tired,"
when they went back scrolling
TikTok 'til 3:00 am.
Yeah, of course.
That's what we all do.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Listen to this --
a professional soccer player
in England
is missing a game tomorrow
because he got a cotton swab
stuck in his ear.
[ Laughter ]
-Johnson & Johnson's like,
"Can we have one good day
of PR?
-"Please."
-Just one?" I mean,
he could remove the Q-Tip,
but he's not allowed.
No hands.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're right, yeah.
No one knows what to do
because it's the first time
a soccer player has had
an injury that's real.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Oh, stop it.
Hey! Oh, hey!
[ Cymbals crash ]
Shawn Mendes is here.
Don't do this!
Don't do this to me
in front of Shawn Mendes.
[ Laughter ]
We had a deal.
Finally, a high school teacher
in California was arrested
after she was allegedly
caught drunk in the classroom.
-Yeah. Drunk while teaching,
or, as parents call that,
homeschooling.
-That's correct.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We have a great show tonight.